people come from all over the world to
come here it's a destination
you're not a typical guitar retail store
there's nothing like this
i've ever seen what is this thing in
this case that's also
a martin this one is twenty thousand
dollars
uh yeah
you gotta check this place out come on
down alex works at the back
so you gotta walk through the cars and
the guitars to get to where he works out
here we go i mean fenders all over the
place
these are new guitars they also have
some vintage stuff also have a lot of
great acoustics
amazing amazing amazing martin guitars
in fact i bought a martin here you have
to play every single one if you're going
to think about buying one
but that's the whole idea if you have
enough of them you can get the different
kind of feel because each one's unique
this is vintage
who knows what country star played that
100 years ago that's my kind of idea
you know displaying them like art if you
like instruments
you'll fall in love with this place all
right we're at alex's workbench
alex jones the legendary guitar tech
here in wall grace
two reasons for me to be here number one
is i'm picking up a 1967
telecaster with a bixby tremolo bar on
it which is very rare and i asked him to
do a setup on it and he
told me you know in texting me that
there's some issues with the guitar
going to find out what those are right
now
you'd expect that with a 67 on the other
hand pretty rare guitar and i wanted it
to be el supreme i want to put new tens
on it
and have everything checked out so let's
start let's learn about what happened
with the 67
telly what he's done to it i'm going to
play it check it out
also today and just get the get the
whole get the news from alex about
what's going on guitars right now here
we go
alex baby how are you hey very good how
about yourself good to see you
so let's start with my um tele my 67
yes you've had it for a couple of weeks
right yes yes it's all done
what have you learned about this guitar
well it plays very well
it looks like it's had frets once at
least right
yeah you would expect that from 67
wouldn't you yeah
and a player guitar you know it might
have had frights done several times but
it looks really clean whoever did the
work did a good job what's the story on
the tremolo bar is that unique
um yeah they're not on every telly
obviously
and it's very similar to the bixby
this one though is drilled a little off
center you can see the line doesn't so
when the guy built the guitar whoever
the maker was back in probably
two years before this maybe yeah it
could have been c6
he screwed it he might have had a
hangover in the morning that's
possible but guitars weren't worth as
much back then you know so he just
didn't he just screwed it in so that's a
little crooked who cares
yeah i think i mean it doesn't look
there are ways to make it come out
straight every time and obviously they
didn't do that
but that's part of the guitar's
personality yeah it it would
i guess you know it would be ideal if it
was you know from a
technical standpoint if the string was
straight yeah but it still works
and it plays really good and it's part
of history now what made you become a
guitar attack
how how what draw you to do this because
you're getting if you go online not to
i don't want to make your head explode
but you're all over the place online
people are talking about your work
jonesified yeah it's a
thing my friend came up with he said
that when i work on a guitar it's been
jonesified
yeah because when i went online in miami
said who's the best guitar tech there
was no question it was you so how did
you
get that way did you train for that are
you an engineer what do you have to do
you were your guitar maker
that's funny my dad my granddad's an
engineer and my dad is an engineer and i
went my own way
so um i wanted to be a musician
and uh musicians are flaky people so i
ended up
working on my own doing this you know
yeah so
so you're a musician and you're also a
guitar tech
where do you really make your living oh
definitely
only play for fun now it's yeah the
technical it's tough to make money as a
musician right
yeah it is especially now where there's
no gigs a lot of guys would make money
doing gigs and selling merch and
yeah that kind of thing and uh it's hard
to get a gig now
the tech business i mean it's sort of an
independent thing right
yeah i mean one option you would have is
to go work for guitar company right
yeah i started working for as a
contractor for a guitar center
i did three years there after i in the
back of guitar center and i was out in
the front and all the noise and that's
one of the reasons why i quit
because it's just crazy it was insane to
try to concentrate in that place
yeah everybody's playing guitar but
baptized by fire you know it couldn't
have gotten any worse
and then and how did you end up here in
walgreens this is kind of a really funky
place
uh yeah i'm fortunate enough cars to run
into
some cool people along the way that
enjoyed my work and
um wrote good reviews online apparently
yeah and uh i guess what this guy's had
is this is his third location
uh when i say this guy i mean bill the
owner yeah he had another
two other locations and every time
someone would come in they would say hey
can i work on your guitar
and guys would be like no jones does
this and no one else touches mike so he
heard my name a million times
before i was even interested in working
here yeah
and then um yeah so i was looking
to move to nashville and i was looking
at advertisements in nashville
as a tech you wanted to move i just
wanted to get the heck out of south
florida because i've been here my whole
life and i just wanted to you know
something different
and i thought it was a bigger music
scene anyway i just was looking at
other options i'm sure everyone has
moments where they think about what
other things could they do or where
could they do it at
so i was looking at that and i saw an
advertisement for
walt grace tech you know and i said
that's a nice place i looked it up i go
dang that's real
fancy i didn't know it was that cool so
i called and
they had this space you know empty
and uh they wanted me to send in a
resume but when i left my name
i got a call back in five minutes on a
sunday
that says you don't need a resume yeah
it's basic it's great
and that was the beginning of a
wonderful relationship yeah yeah bill's
been real good to me
uh i told him what i want he gave it to
me and what did you rent this space from
him so like a boutique or you have some
economics no i'm a salary guy here i
mean look at this place it's magnificent
there's nothing like it uh anywhere
really yeah
so it's a blessing that it came to miami
what kind of people do you meet in here
because i mean you can get people
into cars and obviously guitars that's a
different kind of subset when you think
about it yeah yeah there's some
places that would sell a lot of nice
guitars
you know but this this is just another
thing people come from all over
the world to come here yeah it's a
[Music]
destination
[Music]
i like it did a great job did a great
job on this
vince let's talk about the business here
because this is
a little funky chicken when i walked
into the first time i saw vintage
guitars
and i saw new guitars and i saw cars
what is the vision for this business
what are you operating here part of this
get you going get you started with your
first guitar
or if you're a collector to get you the
best instrument you can ever find
as well for cars so you you have
multiple brands this is epiphone right
this is type of phones
to me this is an entry level guitar as
an investment yes
it's not i don't think these things
appreciate value that much over time at
least you learn how to play
yes this is what's going to get you
started basically okay but it's not this
is here so that you can be a guitar
store
yes uh but part of the concept is that
we want people to play guitar
this we want to get help you achieve
your dream part of the dream just
can't afford a really heavy duty piece
this is where you come
now this looks like les paul to me
yeah les balls gibsons overall we have a
little bit of everything sg's
uh junior special now are these all new
guitars
uh most of them some of them are used uh
this actually looks vintage but it's
actually an aged guitar yeah
it's a newer guitar that's a whole new
thing now right make it look
yeah okay but let me ask you about the
cost of this
as an investment do you have to buy
these guitars put up capital so that you
own them
then they sit on this wall or is this on
consignment sometimes we have we do a
little bit of both yeah
we buy guitars and sell and we also
our dealers for gibson fender and other
brands as well
the big guys like you know the giant
retailers of guitars i used to be in the
i was an investor in fender so i sort of
learned the ways of the world
it's always a balance between how much
of your capital is tied up in these
in this inventory and how much they are
fronting your guitars
depending on your volume of sell-through
right yeah and i mean
you're not a typical guitar retail store
there's nothing like this i've ever
definitely not
i mean so this model works i take it
right
yeah you move a lot of guitars we do new
unused and vintage
yeah we ship nationwide as well now
when you talk gibson as an investment
where do you put it in the pecking order
of things you're putting
you know we're talking to people
thinking all right i'm going to buy a
couple of guitars it's a good investment
i want to play
but would you put what would you put
them into to say look this is going to
appreciate over value over the next 10
years
we're probably going to be looking at
some custom shop guitars which should be
the ones
up there on the top just out of
everybody's reach
yeah hey but everybody can play any
guitar here you come
those are custom-made gibsons les paul
models
yeah there's a little more more more
time costs uh they range
from 5 000 up that's a serious chunk of
change
yeah yeah there's a different process
those are made
there's a lot more hands-on more detail
you know
you know what type of work that alex
does back there so you have a person
actually
takes a closer look at these guitars and
make sure when they come out
and that's a brand new guitar five to
seven thousand sort of range yeah
and then if i held on to it for 10 years
it would be worth more than i paid for
it
it'll maintain it will be worth more yes
okay
so it's worth so that's sort of the
entry level price for an investment
grade guitar
yes but also there's a part where you
can find
really you know appropriately priced
vintage instruments
that are going to appreciate in the
future so we have a little already
appreciated but they're going to go up
more
yeah okay this looks like fender to me
yes fender's interesting
because we have telecasters we have
stratocasters
uh these are rock and roll iconic
brands obviously yeah but you have some
pretty funky looking
fenders here is that again made to look
old up here that's brand new actually
came in last week
you're kidding that's what they call a
relic my friend there's a custom shop
guitar as well
that's your custom custom shop uh
so again they get a lot more time you
know so what would that cost
even though it's a brand new guitar made
to look old uh that one's
uh in the 4 000 area and i can buy just
a standard
stratocaster for what uh they start in
about
about a thousand dollars okay and
they're they're a brand new strat
brand new strat yeah so that's not going
to appreciate value too much over time
right
not compared to the custom shop stuff so
really what we're learning here is if
you
if you want to make an investment in a
guitar you're going to have to come in
at somewhere between five and seven
thousand dollars to retain that value
maybe a little less but yeah that's
around around that yeah is this a joke
over here
uh no yes i know
it's a very interesting base we actually
have a guitar as well
uh builder makes those and they actually
sound really really good
they're interesting i bet you that's
quite controversial
yeah yeah no questions
looks like it's been stressed made to
look old yes
that is a classic fender base yeah
this one over here is actually a vintage
one that's vintage
what would that cost uh this one 12 000
wow that's not cheap it's a jazz bass
yeah
and then again you'll see it right next
to a brand new one you know these are
new fenders the boxer series so
you can either get started with us you
know start your journey your dream
and you can finish it with us as well so
at the end of the day it looks like
you've got hundreds of guitars
because we haven't even talked about the
acoustics yet
yeah so let's go into the acoustic room
now martin guitar is expensive
it can be yes what's the set let's let's
talk about that so you can start with
something like this they're going to be
799 and that's a martin that's a martin
yep
really that's a martin uh
it's all wood as well
[Music]
it's nice from the road tell us not el
supremo though
not necessarily but if you want to get
started with a martin
that's definitely a you know it's a good
option right now we have a lot of
vintage pieces
uh this is a really nice guitar has a
lot of details of the
triple zero 42. what does this cost
that one is going to be or is it i think
it's around 6 000
yeah now would you put this in in the
area of appreciation
i believe so yeah yeah these are guitars
look at the detail on that guitar
they're obviously handmade you don't get
that with the other
uh models uh and it's a it's a classic
model as well
but i can tell it's also got a much
richer sound to it too yeah
especially for a little bit of a smaller
box too
so again same story if you want
something that's going to go up in value
you've got to step up
yeah i mean so the real dilemma is if
you've never played a guitar
why would you spend 7 000 just to become
a beginner
unless you really thought you were going
to follow through yeah i mean
the what they call the beginner guitars
nowadays they're great guitars or
guitars that will last you
your lifetime like those strats those
telecasters even the epic 100 000
yeah that guitar you know they're really
solid guitars you don't
not because you're buying entry level
guitar means you're buying
crap you know you're that those are
solid guitars you can
probably use it the rest of your life
that could be your your one and only
guitar but when you're talking about
investment and collecting you know that
you want to look at
other pieces what is this thing in this
case
so that just came in uh recently that's
also a martin
yeah uh this one is twenty thousand
dollars
uh yeah randy will give you a lot more
details about this guitar
uh this one here's a 37 i believe no 20
1924
so it's 20 000 because it's really old
that one's really old and pretty rare as
well especially you know to have in that
condition there's a really 100 years on
this one
so is this something you take in
consignment and if you sell it you get a
commission on it sort of thing
yes anyway say you have twenty thousand
dollars that's serious money
that's an investment yeah if you like
that video
where did you see my next one don't
forget to click right over here
and subscribe